hey everyone Alessandra here and we've
got some destiny to content to share
with you for more info on what's
happening in the online shooter check
back with our channel for other videos
and features about the game thanks for
watching
destiny - brings many changes in the
next adventure for the Guardians with
new gear mission types and other
gameplay system is being introduced it's
a little hard to keep track of what's
new and what's more the same if you're a
returning player still used to the way
destiny 1 operated it's important to
single out the most important updates
and tweaks in destiny - some of which
shake up what people are normally
customed - but whether you've played the
first game or not here's a quick list of
things to note before starting destiny -
and what to expect when diving in once
you boot up destiny - you'll likely be
in a mad dash to get your levels in gear
up to par to take down the forces of the
red Legion the game has made a number of
changes in tweaks that make the general
grind more palatable and less of a
hassle than in destiny 1 unfortunately
some of the more subtle changes were
kept vague and obtuse destiny 2 drops
random perk roles in the need to level
up weapons and armor which required
breaking in your gear before taking on
the strikes and raids but the most
important change comes from the internal
calculator that determines gear drops in
destiny 1 players what I have to equip
their most powerful gear to yield the
best results from decryption opening
loot chests and regular drops from
bosses Bungie has since rectified this
court by reading your entire inventory
to determine what level of drops you
receive so feel free to use whatever
gear you like as the game will know what
your maximum power level is when the
loot starts to drop
with their lights stripped away you'll
be put through your paces once again in
order to prove yourself as a true
guardian of the light while you start
off with the familiar subclasses from
destiny one the voidwalker striker and
gunslinger soon after you are restricted
to the new arts trader Don guard and
Sentinel subclasses from there
the game doesn't quite explain what
happens next in the evolution of your
class which may make some of the
returning players feel anxious the
process of attaining your second and
third subclass in testing too happens a
lot differently and will take some extra
work when opening up loot chests getting
drops from high-profile targets and
raiding lost sector caches there's a
chance that you'll acquire a class
artifact as random drops these artifacts
will allow you to learn the ways of the
other subclasses charge these relics up
by taking out enemies and completing
public events across the sector's and
then you'll be tasked with the returning
to the shard of the traveler to unlock
the next subclass as of now there are
two subclasses to unlock after the first
one with the final ones being the return
of the taken King subclasses stormcaller
sunbreaker
in Knights talk
though the drops are random they're not
overly rare and you'll gain them in due
time in the original game taking part in
public events was a staple of exploring
the open areas on each planet with big
set-piece encounters focused on taking
down the powered up targets and machines
of war Guardians would have to work
together to eliminate the threat in a
short span of time while these events
return in destiny - and are much easier
to track thanks to the director map
joined timers and upcoming events there
have also been some changes to them that
aren't as clear and could be a valuable
opportunity to take part in early on in
the new public events which are similar
to the original in execution there's a
way to trigger harder variations of
these challenges in one example the
Fallen in the EDC setup machines to
extract glimmer by destroying several
extraction machines instead of focusing
on the main targets you'll activate a
new encounter with the squad of elite
fallen who arrived to take out the
Guardians ruining their operation every
public event has a heroic encounter
option which offers greater rewards but
is much more difficult if you're feeling
bold enough and have a crew up for the
challenge take the opportunity to dive
into these heroic events
the same way you finish everything
Guardian with flair stand down
aside from the Guardians your ghosts and
all the weapons you acquire one of the
most iconic aspects of destiny is the
sparrow a fast moving mount that lets
you dart across the map with ease
however the sparrow is unusually absent
in the early hours of destiny to a far
cry from destiny one which seemed eager
to get the vehicle into your hands
early on the new maps you'll explore are
large and scope making for a lot of
ground to cover
while sparrows are in destiny - and with
exotic variations to obtain acquiring
one has been pushed till later in the
game according to the developers the
reason for making the sparrow a
late-game reward was to encourage
players to explore and be aware of their
surroundings while taking in a number of
side events and exploring the hidden
dungeons throughout so rest easy and
take in the sights while on your travels
there's more to come with destiny -
content on GameSpot so be sure to check
out our other guides about all things
happening in the new shared world
shooter with new secrets and discoveries
still being uncovered there still a lot
to show in the worlds you'll explore
check out our tips for returning players
how to find the heroic public events and
which class is right for you on our
channel thanks for watching